الى انطاكيا تكاثفت اسره سعوديه وتركيا
لمواجهه تاثيرات مريره سببها زلزال السادس
من فبراير علاقه الاسرتين تعود لعقدين
عندما حدث خطا طبي واستبدلوا طفليهما
بمستشفى حادثه لا زالت تفاصيلها تؤثر على
حياتهم
قبل اكثر من 20
سنه عندما استبدلت اسرتين سعوديه وتركيا
طفليهما بعد خطا في مستشفى جنوبيه
السعوديه هنالك في نجران اليوم وبعد 20
سنه هذا هو يعقوب اليامي يعين رفقه والده
السابق يوسف التركي منزلهم المدمر في
انطاكيا بعد زلزال السادس من فبراير حسينا
بهزه يعني البيت يهتز رح نتشمعنا في مكان
واحد جلسنا بعد ما وقف الزلزال بشوي
حاولنا نخرج مع
الباب ننزل الدور جدي
وفيه كانت هناك مرات عمي واولادها حاولنا
نساعدهم واخرجهم من البيت
بعد ما خرجنا يعني كان الجو ممطر وكان في
جيراني يبغون مساعدات حاولنا نساعد بعض
الجيران اللي كانوا جنبنا بعدين خلينا
العائله وبعدها من البيت
يوسف التركي الذي احتضن يعقوب بعد ولادته
بدقائق اعتقادا منه انه ابنه قبل ان يكتشف
عكس ذلك بسنوات كان في نجران وقت الزلزال
هرع الى تركيا ولم يكن وحيدا بل رافقه
والد يعقوب السعودي محمد اليامي
وقف يعقوب مع اخواته مع عائلته مع اهله
يعني ما أني من كل المتفرقين من
توسلات الاهل والاصدقاء ليعقوب بالعوده
الى السعوديه بعد وقوع الزلزال لم تكن
مزتيا
كلموني قال ابغاك الحمد لله بخير
وكلنا سليم نحمد الله لكن ما اقدر يعني
لازم اساعد اللي هنا لازم اساعدها
خطا مستشفى نجران قبل نحوي عقدين من
الزمان جعل ليعقوب اخا اسمه علي لازال
يتقن شيئا من اللهجه النجرانيه يحمل
الجنسيه السعوديه ويعيش في العاصمه
التركيه انقره
وانا يعقوب ساعدنا اهلنا في الخروج من
المنزل
واخذناهم الى منطقه امنه بعدها
شعلنا النار كي ندفع
تقريبا بعد 15 ساعه كذا توصلنا على اهلنا
في السعوديه
عشان نخبرهم من الخير
يعقوب قدر له ان يعيش حياتين في نجران
كمقيم وفي تركيا كمواطن في السعوديه انا
مقيم هناك واعاني في بعض الامور اذا رحت
مكان ولا حاجه يعني يكون السعوديين
يبدونهم قدام انا اكون دائما في الخدمه
ونفس الكلام ينطبق في تركيا يعني ما يقدر
يسوي اي شيء
في السعوديه
في اسم ابو السعودي ويعقوب باقي على
جنسيته التركيه في اسمي انا يعني نبغى اقل
حاجه نعدلني اياها في كل واحد في اسمه
جنسيتين يعني
اخذنا يعقوب الى حيث سينام اليوم برفقه
والده التركي خيمه لاحد اقربائهم الاتراك
وقادنا الى خيم المساعدات السعوديه التي
وصلت انطاكيا وبعثت فيه الحنين لوطنه لابد
يعني لقدك تشوف دولتك الام تساعد دوله
ثانيه او مثل ما تضرين من الزلزال في
تركيا او في سوريا يعني يتشرف الواحد
ويعتزل بدولته انها تساعدوا الناس محتاجين
لا يشعر يعقوب بالغربه في تركيا
يتجول بين اقربائه الاتراك ويسير دوما
برفقه والده التركي الذي لا يفرق بينه
وبين ابنائه عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
انطاكيا